listen when your knowledge nor it's
stressful it's lonely it is like
everything is on me right like
everything's broken of vaynermedia the
more you are successful have this gutter
dirt work ethic about them is really
almost loaded it's like you have it's
like you have the demeanor of a king and
clean cleaning crew
you know values but you have to work
like a [ __ ] peasant especially about
the industry you know how people have
committed suicide and a tech startup
community last five years and there's
not a super battle entrepreneurship is
on the pedestal and everything takes it
easy it's on you there's no blaming
anybody if this wins you if this loses
you that's loneliest Rock I have pain
there's all these problems but when I'm
in pain I go to sleep for five minutes
then I wake up the next day and I kiss
the world
when you're the CEO when you're the
founder every single thing that happens
in this company that's wrong is my fault
you know how tough it is when you have
nobody else to blame how much fun it is
for you to blame the person that's above
you
oh it's iheartradio spawn oh it's it's
Pittman Saul it's my boss's car that's
fun it's very tough to be at the top of
something you know what is going great
[Music]
it is lonely at the top it's only my
responsibility
it's only my singular responsibility at
the end of the day the buck stops with
me and I have to with every ounce of my
soul try to deploy my North Star to my
employees it's fun and I love this space
the most I loved it long before athletes
and celebrities and rappers wanted to be
entrepreneurs it was my destiny it was
who I was it was how I was wired it was
the only thing I knew my entire life is
taking care of crap putting out fires
24/7 365 my whole life is this is a
problem fix this and guess what when
you're the last line of the fence
there's no blaming your boss every day's
hard and that's the best [ __ ] part of
it I'm going to always capitalize on
that you know and I believe that it's
time like all these great to die now I
mean really great so many people that we
can look up to and I don't have a
problem being one of those people
[Music]
[Music]